put on a few pounds in the uh quarantine
i think we all put all the pandemic
weight the grub hub the seamless i got
to cut back because i was a fat kid that
was huge i had man boobs growing up
isn't that weird about men when men gain
weight we grow female body parts right
like ladies you don't have to worry
about that like if a woman gains weight
just become a fat lady if a guy gains
weight we also become a fat lady
we don't grow male body parts not like
yeah i saw tammy by the river
she had a set of balls on
her there were some perks being a fat
kid i'd go to a sleepover my friend's
like i wonder what it's like to touch a
boob i'm like you're in luck
nobody likes man boobs i've asked around
i've done the research nobody likes a
hairy milkless tit
and yet man boobs are legal all over the
country
fat guy in cleveland take his shirt off
totally fine woman in cleveland takes
her shirt off in decent exposure but
those are the tits we like how do we
[ __ ] that up
we got weird boob rules in america
female tit exposed illegal male 2
exposed legal female to exposed of the
baby sucking on it legal melted exposed
to the baby sucking on it very illegal
weird rules
this is how i look at it female tits are
like marijuana fun harmless yet still
mostly criminalized oh
man boobs are like cigarettes kind of
gross off-putting why the [ __ ] do you
bring those to the beach
we legalized the wrong one
you know what shocks me speaking of tits
my girlfriend's got huge knobs and uh
like like women have to walk into a
store and go i'm a bee i'm a c i'm a d
guys aren't that strong if a guy had to
walk around going i'm an a he'd kill
himself
that wouldn't last 20 minutes right
some guy jump off a building suicide
note a minus every time every time